economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida eeuu a la unión europea
se pusieron de acuerdo por primera vez
en dos décadas y daniele le preguntó
sobre que se pusieron de acuerdo
raúl sobre nada más y nada menos que
sobre aranceles la guerra comercial
entre eeuu y la unión europea data de
hace casi 20 años por cuenta de los
subsidios a hierbas que eeuu consideró
perjudicial es para boix y en los
últimos meses se ha venido recrudeciendo
con impuestos de la casa blanca pero en
un giro inesperado parece que la
atención está bajando y ambas partes
acordaron una reducción arancelaria en
varios productos valorada en unos 200
millones de dólares para el caso de eeuu
las langostas ingresarán sin arancel a
europa y en contraparte washington
reduce a la mitad los gravámenes sobre
alimentos preparados vidrio cerámica y
encendedores desechables faltan aún las
aprobaciones parlamentarias así de
daniela y siguiendo con temas de la
unión europea uno
las conversaciones del acuerdo post
break sit terminó la séptima ronda de
negociaciones para un pacto comercial
después del divorcio entre el reino
unido y este bloque comunitario que
recordemos fue el 31 de enero pero en
términos de acuerdos alcanzados es como
si hubiera sido la primera ronda raúl
porque todavía no hay nada y wiiware
sentimos muchas veces esta semana como
si retrocediéramos en lugar de ir hacia
adelante dado el poco tiempo que queda
lo que dije en londres en julio sigue
siendo cierto hoy en esta etapa un
acuerdo entre el reino unido y la unión
europea parece muy poco probable
simplemente no entiendo por qué estamos
perdiendo un tiempo tan valioso
westin
y es que a cinco meses del inicio de las
conversaciones todavía los temas de
pesca y de competencia están bloqueando
la agenda y si en octubre no se logra un
texto jurídico por lo menos es muy
difícil que en diciembre haya un pacto
comercial firma y el plazo se vence el
31 de diciembre daniel y los
trabajadores de una de las minas de
carbón más grandes del mundo votaron por
irse a huelga sí señor se trata del
cerrejón en colombia que es una de las
operaciones a cielo abierto más grandes
del mundo y que tiene más de 5 mil
trabajadores pues un sindicato votó a
favor de una huelga pues pide un aumento
salarial del 6 por ciento pero la
empresa que es propiedad de las
británicas veis billiton y anglo
american además de la suiza glencore
ofrece la mitad de este aumento que
ellos están pidiendo vienen compañeros
10 días muy importantes para nuestra
organización y para el proceso de
negociación y para las decisiones
trascendentales que deben tomarse frente
al conflicto que vamos a librar estamos
a 10 días de definir la hora cero
enviamos un mensaje a la empresa
cerrejón que modifique su posición en la
mesa
pues de concretarse esta huelga raúl se
suspendería a gran parte de las ventas
del quinto exportador mundial de carbón
que es colombia así es daniela y por
primera vez en cinco meses brasil generó
más empleos de lo que destruyó si las
medidas de aislamiento impuestas para
contener la pandemia han cobrado
alrededor de 1,1 millones de puestos de
trabajo en los primeros siete meses del
año esto debido a que casi nueve
millones de personas han sido despedidas
en lo que va de 2020 pero también otras
78 millones han sido contratadas según
el gobierno entre marzo y junio siempre
eran las más las personas despedidas que
las contratadas como vemos en el gráfico
sobre todo en abril cuando la crisis se
sintió con más fuerza pero ya en julio
se revirtió la tendencia y se crearon
131 mil plazas laborales pero no hay que
olvidar que la tasa de desempleo está
por encima del 13% y que se estima que
casi tres de millones de personas están
buscando empleo en este país
daniela indicadores como cerrar los
mercados o el viernes de fin de semana
raúl 'wall street' el cerro de nuevo en
positivo al igual que ayer animado por
el impulso de la actividad
en agosto que comenzó a recuperarse y
por la acción de apple que subió más del
5% en cambio las bolsas europeas bajaron
después de que se conocieran más los
datos sobre la actividad empresarial en
ese continente y en américa latina hubo
resultados mixtos con una ligera alza en
la bolsa de sao paulo por este buen dato
de empleo del que acabamos de hablar
para finalizar daniela que nos trae hoy
como cifra el día bueno son los 2,2
billones de euros
esta es la deuda del reino unido porque
tocó un máximo histórico y además superó
el 100 por ciento de su producto interno
bruto como también lo están haciendo
otros países de europa raúl y daniela
como siempre ha sido un placer conversar
de temas económicos con usted que tenga
una muy buena noche y un feliz fin de
semana y ustedes también que tengan un
fin de semana feliz hasta aquí esta
crónica de economía en france 24
continúan con nosotros buena noche
i